il faut noter bien entendu france roche
mais je pense c'est volontaire que nous
dans cet extrait du film nous n'avons
pas vu le célèbre hit i alors vous
maintenant vous êtes là pour nous en
parler justine et mathilde vous avez vu
ce film
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il évoque
pour vous pourquoi l'avez vous aimez
aussi bien vous m'avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est génial a bien mais
expliquez vous ça veut dire quoi
quelle conne la première fois qu'on le
voit on pleure on rit on a toutes sortes
d'émotions et est généralement qu'on
voit un film c'est soit on pleure soir
il n'y a pas les deux en même temps et
l'ail et les 2es et beaucoup d'autres
émotions
c'est une raison pour laquelle vous avez
mais ce fait et vous mathilde qui m'a
beaucoup impressionné pourquoi parce que
il était tellement mignon mais en fait
il était très laid c'est ce mélange de
millions de lei qui vous a plu et vous
vous voyez vous avez dix ans et elliot
le petit héros de ce film qui recueille
et qui protège les ti à 10 ans aussi
vous vous êtes imaginer dans sa
situation
non pas du tout même s'il existait est
ce que vous pensez d'abord qu'il existe
des outils des créatures extraterrestres
mais j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils exigent
i tahiti pourquoi parce que j'aime
bouger j'aime beaucoup sa figure et vous
maintiennent ça vous plairait que vous
êtes vous croyez qu'il en existe
pourquoi et qu'il ya des créatures d'un
autre monde que nous sommes pas seuls
sur terre je pense qu'il y à toute
créature vous le pensez vous moi je
pense qu'il n'existe pas mais
mais rien d'essayer de penser qu'il
existe ça fait un corpus imaginer
autrement dit dans ce film vous préférez
iti au petit garçon qui s'appelle henry
thomas qui est le héros du film
mouais pourtant il est plus joli mais
c'est toujours les petits acteurs qui
sont les qui sont le plus important
général et là c'est justement une
créature une créature mignonne qui qui
est intelligente et ne pas voir les
bleus portent cette créature que vous
qualifiez deux fois de suite deux
mignonnes
le moins qu'on puisse dire footix
correspond pas aux thermes mignon du
vocabulaire à 8 heures au rocher avec
ses gros yeux son dos tout courbet ce
coup assez invraisemblable parce que là
encore la maquette est beaucoup plus
agréable que la vraie facture mais elle
a un doigt particulièrement important
avec lequel d'ailleurs elle elle
communique
ça aussi ça a dû vous plaît vous savez
quel servette a été fait a été commandée
par spielberg est un spécialiste de ce
genre d'objet d'après un mélange de
photos de bébés et de photos de einstein
et du poète carl sandburg parce qu'il
paraît que le regard est inspiré de
celui d'einstein et le la naïveté par
les visages d'enfants et quelqu'un m'a
dit ce matin que c'était exactement le
visage d'un embryon
alors donc c'est pour cela sans doute
que les enfants rendent monte à un
espèce de monde près génitales mais lui
steven spielberg aime beaucoup
travailler avec les enfants envoyés plus
même peut-être qu'avec les bébêtes
extraterrestres et nous allons le voir
il va nous expliquer ça